débat sur le budget le gouvernement
engage sa responsabilité
résultat du vote ce soir fin du sommet
franco-britannique pas de concessions
anglaise sur l'europe verte y rendit
nouveaux otages libérés mais tous les
autres seront jugés
là messieurs bonsoir avant de rentrer en
détail dans le déroulement de la journée
au palais bourbon nous allons tout
d'abord évoqué les premiers résultats du
sommet franco britannique qui vient de
s'achever à londres résultat pas très
encourageant chacune des délégations
conduites par marc et s'assure d'une par
valéry giscard d'estaing de l'autre
n'ayant pas cédé d'un pouce sur ses
positions respectives
les britanniques maintiennent
l'intégralité de leurs exigences
exigences vous le savez assez
restrictive en matière de budget et
d'agriculture communautaire bref un
véritable dialogue de sourds qui ne peut
guère contribué à faire avancer la
construction européenne
d'abord valéry giscard d'estaing nous
éprouvons de la compréhension pour la
situation causée pour la grande bretagne
par l'application des règles en vigueur
et notamment celles qui découlent du
traité d'adhésion comme celles qui
découlent de l'accord intervenu à dublin
en 1975
mais d'autre part nous souhaitons peut
rencontrer la compréhension de la part
de la grande bretagne sur le fait que la
solution doit être recherchée dans le
respect des règles communautaires et en
associant l'ensemble des pays de la
communauté à la solution de ce problème
il faut rappeler la communauté a déjà
connu des difficultés de cette nature et
que en règle générale des solutions ont
pu être trouvées et ses difficultés ont
été surmontées
mais elles ont été surmontées en raison
des deux conditions suivantes d'abord
que chacun tienne compte des intérêts
légitimes de tous ses autres partenaires
puisqu'il s'agit de problèmes
communautaires et ensuite que tous
respectent les prix
si et au delà même la logique de
l'organisation de la communauté principe
est logique qui sont à distance âme si
on veut poursuivre le développement
développement que les circonstances
internationales actuelles rendent me
semble-t-il plus nécessaire que jamais
le brillant ne s'est pas tout à fait
lever ni sur la tamise ni sur la
situation exacte de la communauté
pendant deux jours on aime sa chair avec
son sourire et son regard bleu immuable
a répété je suis européenne mon
gouvernement et pour l'europe mais il
faudrait que le même aménager les règles
de la communauté européenne pour tenir
compte de notre situation particulière
un nouveau britannique je suis giscard
d'estaing l'a écoutée avec évidemment
beaucoup de courtoisie car bien entendu
le climat de cette rencontre a été
parfaitement cordiale mais monsieur
giscard d'estaing est resté lui aussi
très fermement sur ses positions
mais la question qu'on peut se poser à
l'issue de ces deux journées de
discussions difficiles
c'est au fond quelle est la nature du
problème y at il un problème franco
britannique que monsieur giscard
d'estaing a dit non il n'y a pas de
problème propre britannique il ya un
problème européen qu'il s'agisse de hp
le ter va verser aux finances
européennes et qu'il s'agisse du désir
anglais de voir les français acheter
leur mouton et qu'il s'agisse du
l'hégire étonnement manifesté par les
européens à la vie du prix auquel les
britanniques veulent vendre leur pétrole
il s'agit bien le problème non pas
franco britannique mais européen donc de
problèmes à régler dans une dizaine de
jours à dublin
non pas à deux mais à neuf voilà et puis
toujours en toile de fond cette question
est-ce que l'ancrage de la grande
bretagne à l'europe est ce que cet
ancrage est véritablement profond et
définitif
oui les agriculteurs français s'en sont
pris cet après midi à la politique
britannique précisément près de 15000
agriculteurs qui ont cet après-midi
allant écouter françois guillaume le
président de la fnsea critiqué avec
virulence la politique à l'école de nos
partenaires
si le gouvernement français ne se
montrent pas assez ferme avec les
anglais la volonté syndicale s'y
substituera d'une c'est guillaume tout
ça donc à laon dans l'aisne
nous attendons donc maintenant à ce qui
s'est passé aujourd'hui à l'assemblée
nationale dès va à vrai dire sans
surprise pour lequel le gouvernement a
engagé sa responsabilité
on serait tenté de dire sans risque dès
lors que le rpr avait annoncé son
intention de ne pas voter la censure
on assista donc aux défilés des grands
taylor des grands ténors pardon à la
tribune à la floraison de petites
phrases qui feront date tels la
sinistrose qui a dénoncé raymond barre
ou bien le petit doigt sur la couture du
pantalon dont s'est moqué françois
mitterrand en constatant avec regret ce
qui était devenu l'acte majeur de la
fonction parlementaire
pour le reste un élément nouveau alors
que les premiers votes se déroule en ce
moment même la décision des socialistes
de voter la motion de censure communiste
le groupe communiste de son côté avait
fait savoir un peu plus tôt qu'il se
prononcerait en faveur des deux motions
socialiste voici donc un résumé de ce
débat est tout d'abord l'intervention de
françois mi temps monsieur le premier
ministre vous pouvez attendre de nous
que nous respectons la loi de la
démocratie
nous sommes partisans de la vraie paix
civile et si nous sommes vos adversaires
nous sommes pas vos ennemis mais vous ne
pouvez pas attendre de nous la caution
d'une politique dont nous combattons
l'inspiration la conduite et les effets
parce que nous les jugeons nez face au
pays bref le vrai dialogue c'est la
pratique de la démocratie tout
simplement le parti communiste qui
présente son propre texte de motion de
censure regrette lui aussi l'absence de
dialogue
ne cherchez pas non plus à dissimuler
votre opération
sous le prétexte de faire respecter les
droits du parlement et les caricatures
les pires pratiques de la 4e au public
en multipliant les palinodies pour
masquer le refus d'examiner les vrais
problèmes pour les députés appartenant
ou rpr claude labbé le dira ensuite pas
question de voter la censure mais la
critique est sévère roger chinaud pour
l'udf le lui reprochera
si nous perdions de vue la priorité qui
consiste pour nous parlementaires de la
majorité à rester est né dans notre
action quotidienne alors l'opinion nous
reprocherait d'avoir mis les
institutions et le pays en danger et je
terminerai simplement en disant chers
amis de la majorité
j'espère à bientôt mais le bien tout
n'est pas pour tout de suite du moins si
l'on en croit le discours de michel
debré un discours réquisitoire qui est
une véritable sommation à changer de
politique
sur un ton très gros l'icône et mon
propos comme il convient de le faire non
l'expression d'une guérilla mots que
l'on répète trop souvent à des fins
électorales médiocre mais comme un appel
solennel à l'exécutif appel dont au fond
de vous même vous ne pouvez méconnaître
la valeur dans la situation où nous
sommes et à la veille d'événements
graves dans le monde et qu'ils ne seront
pas seulement économique
le chemin sur lequel vous vous engagez
n'est pas comme il faudrait compte tenu
des circonstances le chemin de la
victoire
le discours du premier ministre semblera
une déclaration de politique générale
avec en prime une réponse directe à
michel debré on parle de crise de régime
il y aurait véritablement crise de
régime si celui-ci était soit contesté
soit menacé or jamais les institutions
la vème république non tu moins de
détracteurs aujourd'hui pourquoi parce
que le peuple les soutient le
gouvernement quant à lui travaillé
continue à travailler
il sait que l'avenir de la france exige
avant tout
patience rigueur et ténacité
ce qui compte à ses yeux c'est de
conduire sans se laisser dévier la
politique qui lui paraît adaptée aux
circonstances actuelles et que jusqu'à
nouvel ordre le pays à approuver bat
donc pour ce résumé signé par jean
mécène donc je le répète le vote et des
trois motions de censure vient de
commencer il y a une
demi-heure tout de suite je vous pose la
question d'aller le bail n'est pas
encore d'indications de vote non n'y a
aucune espèce d'indication pour
l'instant vous voyez du reste que le
vote se poursuit mais je pense qu'en
revanche vous voulez savoir quel est le
climat au sein du groupe rpr
évidemment le groupe qui fait plus visés
oui voici un petit éventail des
qualificatifs employés scandalisé dit
gabriel kaspereit colère déclaré hector
rolland stupéfait par les attaques de
monsieur par contre de bruit renchérit
philippe seguin et plusieurs députés une
dizaine m'affirme ton en t'applaudit
lors de la réunion de groupe
joël le tac lorsqu'il a annoncé qu'il
voterait la censure il avait déclaré je
la voterai car depuis 21 ans je n'ai
jamais entendu traiter de cette passion
le principal pilier de la majorité
monsieur markus a ajouté le premier
ministre se comporte comme si le rpr
c'était le déclin c'était fini mais il
devrait faire attention il y a un
rendez-vous en 1981 enfin dernière
déclaration de monsieur falala un des
vice-présidents du goût le premier
ministre a ressoudé notre groupe il n'y
a plus de nuances monsieur barna de
flamme que lorsqu ils nous attaquent ils
nous des textes bien daniel vous nous
rappeler s'il se passe quelque chose
donc d'ici la fin de journée ou en tout
cas de toute façon
pendant le journal de 23 ans alors je
crois que maintenant peut-être un petit
peu prendre de distance noël copains et
s'interroger un débat utile du cercle en
tout cas un faux débat un curieux débat
oui on serait presque tenté de dire en
tout cas en regardant de loin qu'ils
salissent un peu une comédie dans un
théâtre en rond ou si vous préférez une
corrida sans mise à mort le gouvernement
lui-même s'est prêtée à être une cible
en sachant qu'ils ne seraient pas
touchés le rpr où la vue prononce des
sommations mais ne tire pas et
l'opposition tire en sachant qu'elle
tire à blanc
on pense un peu si vous voulez à ces
rites dans l'est les anthropologues et
les ethnologues nous ont parlé par
lesquels les sociétés primitives ou les
sociétés antiques jouer à renverser à
simuler le renversement du pouvoir pour
finalement mieux le rendre mieux le
renforce
alors au delà du rideau delà des
banderilles a quand même eu un vrai
débat et il ya quand même eu un vrai un
vrai débat et soul et c'est sans doute
l'intérêt de cette journée c'est que ce
débat de censure sur le budget s'est
transformée finalement
en un véritable débat de politique
générale chacun bien sûr tendance à
reprocher à l'autre de ne pas
s'intéresser aux grands problèmes qui
concernent les français mais c'est bien
au niveau de ces grands problèmes qu'il
ya eu affrontement politique et chacun
est venu finalement redéfinir sa
politique et finalement annoncé son ton
bras car film il ya quatre programmes
oui il n'y a plus maintenant une
majorité et une opposition le fait de la
journée c'est sans doute cette rupture
qui s'est aggravée au sein de la
majorité dont daniel brême vient de nous
parler il est vrai que le gouvernement
veut continuer à gouverner sans avoir
une majorité cohérente il lui suffit
d'après la constitution de ne pas avoir
contre lui une nouvelle une autre
majorité cohérente mais on peut bien
dire ce soir qu'il y a quatre familles
politiques etc à travers le débat
d'aujourd'hui il est clair que ces
quatre familles se lance maintenant dans
la campagne une comédie rue disait tout
à l'heure
peut-être vaut-il mieux dire qu'il
s'agit d'une sorte de répétition
générale en vase clos avant les grands
débats publics de demain ou après-demain
matière sociale maintenant potes de
développement spectaculaire des grands
conflits en cours pour alstom c'est
aujourd'hui que roger salmon devait
remettre son rapport au ministre du
travail mais aucune nouvelle ne nous est
parvenue de chez jean matteoli nouvelle
attendue bien sûr avec impatience à
belfort du côté des aiguilleurs du ciel
petit flottement les contrôleurs
s'interroge toujours sur les suites à
donner à la proposition du directeur de
la navigation aérienne qui s'est déclaré
prêt à rencontrer les grévistes
il semble que des contacts soient pris
actuellement pour qu'il y ait une
réunion entre la direction de la
navigation aérienne et les syndicats
pour mercredi ou jeudi
les assemblées générales en tout cas se
succèdent au centre d'athis mons et dans
les autres centres régionaux
elle va faire du monde maintenant avec
tout d'abord bien sûr l'iran les dix
otages que nous vous montrions lié à
dans ce journal ont bel et bien été
libérés ils n'ont fait qu'un bref
passage à orly en fin de matinée à
l'heure du déjeuner vingt minutes sans
que les journalistes puissent les
approcher tout avait été fait pour les
isolés du monde extérieur
les six hommes et les quatre femmes sont
passées presque directement de
l'appareil d'air france
un avion de l'armée américaine qui les
attendait pour les déposer à francfort
12h35 sur l'aéroport militaire américain
francfort l'avion transportant les dix
otages viennent d'atterrir à bord il ya
quatre femmes et six soldats noirs ils
vont rejoindre leurs deux autres
collègues libérer eux aussi et qui sont
hospitalisés depuis hier à l'hôpital de
l'armée de l'air américaine de wiesbaden
les otages sont en bonne santé des
consignes très strictes ont été données
afin qu'ils ne puissent pas communiquer
avec la presse c'est en effet du sort
des autres au sein des autres otages
restants à l'ambassade qu'il s'agit
maintenant les étudiants islamiques ont
annoncé leur intention de les juger pour
espionnage ne les considérant plus cette
fois comme des otages mais comme des
prisonniers
tout cela bien sûr à moins que le chat
ne soit extradé c'est l'exigence des
exit de ses étudiants une exigence à
laquelle le président carter ne cédera
pas le radical de gauche roger gérard
schwartzenberg presse ce soir le bois
mort français de condamner la prise
d'otage de téhéran se taire c'est
consentir dit il l'iran qui demandent ce
soir aux importateurs japonais et
européens de pétrole de ne plus utiliser
les banques américaines pour le paiement
de leur pétrole brut à l'iran on a parlé
d'ailleurs pétrole au 10e sommet arabe
qui s'est ouvert aujourd'hui à tunis
sous la présidence de habib bourguiba le
doyen des chefs d'état arabes
la jordanie a en effet demandé
l'adoption de deux politique pétrolière
l'une à l'égard du monde occidental
l'autre pour les pays en voie de
développement un système bien difficile
à réaliser pour le chèque camani
ministre saoudien du pétrole
ces sommets ne sont pas de pure forme le
premier au caire en 64 avait vu la
création de l'ol paie et c'est celui 73
c'est à dire juste après la guerre du
kippour qui avait décidé de la poursuite
de l'embargo pétrolier pour le monde
occidental aggravation de la tension en
afrique orientale le président de la
zambie ciani aujourd'hui son pays en
état de guerre totale rappelle de tous
les réservistes et annulations des
permissions cela en raison d'une série
d'incidents perpétrés par des commandos
venus d'euros d'ici le député espagnol
ou perez toujours aux mains de ses
ravisseurs cela fait maintenant près
d'une semaine la mère teresa prix nobel
de la paix a lancé aujourd'hui un
appel aux ravisseurs pour qu'ils le
libèrent le député je vous le rappelle
avait été enlevée par le thé à qui
demandent en échange la libération de
cinq de ses membres
le premier ministre hongrois à paris
monsieur lazhar est en france depuis cet
après midi pour une visite officielle de
48 heures but de son voyage
essentiellement économique
la hongrie souhaite en effet accroître
ses relations avec la france qui n'est
actuellement que son quatrième
partenaire quatrième fournisseur avec
maurice werther un regard sur l'économie
assez particulière disons de ce pays
cibles
mais qu'est ce qui fait courir les
hongrois comme ça en cette fin d'année
maussade pour tout le monde la grisaille
de novembre et la vie devenu d'un coup
plus difficile le temps on n'y peut rien
la difficulté d'être cet autre chose et
peut-être on veut dire pourquoi ça ne va
pas si bien et pourquoi les hongrois par
nature port qui à rire ont souvent
défigurent pas bien gai pourquoi c'est
tout simple la hongrie comme les autres
commencent à être touchés par la crise
économique en retard de 10 en cinq ans
de crise nous avons eu vraiment cinq ans
est très très très prospère pendant
lesquelles des jeunes l'occident et
étaient victimes de cette crise
mais malheureusement cette fois ci pour
nous c'est également très préoccupant de
voir les prix grimper à première vue
quand on descend sur le terrain on ne
remarque pas grand chose d'inquiétant
les magasins sont très bien garni toutes
sortes de marchandises des marchandises
d'une qualité acceptable
d'autre part ce ne sont pas les clients
qui manque au rayon d'habillement
d'alimentation ou de produits de beauté
et cette grande surface n'est qu'un
exemple ailleurs séparé mais là où le
bât commence à blesser c'est que depuis
le 23 juillet de cette année le
gouvernement a décidé une hausse brutale
des prix qui pour certaines denrées
alimentaires va jusqu'à 20 30 et même 35
%
et ça lui faire un choc quand même pour
la ménagère hongroise qui commet un tel
régime
c'est vrai mais nous n'avons pas pu
l'éviter
ce parent sur les gens n'étaient pas
très contents mais qu'ils ont taxé
liaison a pris ils ont compris qu'ils
ont compris l'importance
ils ont confié les raisons les ont
compliqué pour vip avec les hongrois ont
ils vraiment accepter ce coup du sort
avec la sérénité que décrit le ministre
du commerce extérieur
il est vrai que pour amortir le coût
tout le salaire ont été un peu augmenté
il est vrai aussi que les hongrois sont
à l'abri d'un souci qui touche les
occidentaux il y a des économistes qui
disent peut être il faudrait une toute
petite dose de chômage parce qu'avec ça
la discipline de travail pourrait être
plus lourd plus rigoureux avec ça le
rendement d'une usine et le rendement
des travailleurs également pourrait être
plus grand mais je pense que tout de
même c'est une grande conquête d'un
régime socialiste de ne pas connaître le
chômage
un tout petit sondage auprès de
consommateurs va nous donner de son de
cloche
ça n'a pas tellement augmenté si j'ai
envie de quelque chose je l'achète quand
même
évidemment ça augmenté mais pas
tellement
et il faut bien manger et n'ont ni les
viandes a beaucoup augmenté
en tout cas pour moi qui suis retraité
attention elle n'a pas beaucoup bougé
ainsi la hongrie occupe une place à part
entre les pays de l'est
si l'on attend 10 minutes pour se faire
servir ce n'est pas grave la marchandise
est là il n'y a pas de pénurie
la distribution est bonne et les clients
en général ont de quoi payer mais avec
la crise économique qui arrive aux
portes
il est à craindre que la hongrie ne
conservera pas éternellement sa
situation privilégiée ce apprend à
l'instant la suite d'une télécabine aux
deux-alpes deux morts et deux blessés
parmi les victimes
le directeur des pistes lucien qu art et
l'un de ses collaborateurs
la station des deux alpes n'est pas
encore ouverte ou skieurs et ouverture
aujourd'hui de la maternité baudelocque
cette maternité avait été fermée vous
vous en souvenez il ya deux mois à la
suite de trois décès de nouveau nés ces
deux mois de fermeture ont permis la
réfection d'une bonne partie
l'établissement
et puis maintenant vous parler d'une
affaire disons assez troublante depuis
cinq ans un homme vit en prison pour le
meurtre d'une vieille dame cet homme de
60 ans s'appelle guy mauvillain et si
nous nous intéressons ce soir à son cas
c'est parce que depuis cinq ans il clame
son innocence sans bruit sans haine
guy mauvillain condamné à 18 ans de
réclusion criminelle a confiance en la
justice de son pays voilà cinq ans que
prêt à sortir de prison
il n'a toujours pas défait ses valises
c'est ici dans cette maison de l'avenue
guiton à la rochelle que le 9 janvier
une vieille dame de 76 ans est lâchement
assassiné avant de tomber dans le coma
elle murmure c'est le mari de madame
mauvillain l'infirmière qui fait des
piqûres madame mauvillain connaît cette
dame soignante à l'hôpital de la
rochelle elle a été amenée à lui
prodiguer des soins
ses derniers mots alors une accusation
un appel une méprise guy mauvillain
arrêté par la police ni sa culpabilité
madame mauvillain elle
est persuadée de l'innocence de son mari
tout comme ses avocats et presque tous
ceux qui ont eu l'occasion d'approcher
le dossier il doute
j'ai été frappé par l'acharnement que
mettait cette femme à défendre son mari
madame mobile à est une femme simple
mais qui à cette intelligence du coeur
dont le par le basque al c'est une femme
fatiguée mais c'est également une femme
courageuse
il est difficile de rester indifférent à
son combat personnel plus je connais ce
dossier et plus je suis inquiet et j'ai
peur que cette agression ait fait non
pas une seule victime sept ports auriez
femme qui est décédée
mais quel en effet également d'autres à
savoir y movida que je ne connais pas du
tout et son épouse que je connais et que
j'estime beaucoup aux assises
guy mauvillain est présenté comme un
chômeur professionnel sans le sou sans
domicile fixe voici le domicile des
mobil 1 là où les policiers sont venus
l'arrêter quelques jours avant le crime
il a gagné une coquette somme au tiercé
et les certificats de ses employeurs
sont tous élogieux
j'en citerai un un homme d'une valeur
exceptionnelle et d'une honnêteté au
dessus de tout soupçon
visiblement la réalité ne colle pas avec
le portrait fait de cet homme aux
assisses présente les assises comme une
cure et inserts concon cercle la voilà
exactement ce que je me suis représenté
dès la 6 je me battrai monsieur mba
traiter jusqu'à la fin de mes jours
mais ça je ne le laisserai pas présents
savent pour être sûrs que nous allons
peu avant l'heure du crime trois témoins
ont vu des personnes rodez à côté de la
maison de la victime
aucun n'a reconnu mobile pourtant la
malchance va s'acharner sur l'accusé son
avocat de l'époque spécialiste de droit
commercial plaide pour la première fois
aux assises c'est un homme de dossier il
ne prend pas garde au climat de l'époque
et la malchance veut que le procès
s'ouvre au moment où se produire une
série d'agressions contre des personnes
âgées un témoignage important n'est pas
entendue alors aux assises celui de
madame frétard la voisine qui habite la
maison contiguë à celle des époux mobil
1 m'apprêtais à descendre pour aller aux
toilettes au moment du film s'est passé
le crayon et vous avez entendu ces
bruits de cuisine en entend bien ici
alors devient très bien guy mauvillain a
toujours déclaré être chez lui en train
de préparer le repas au moment du crime
pourtant ce nouveau témoignage ne sera
pas retenu par le ministère de la
justice
pour accéder à la requête en révision du
procès le procureur lui-même dans son
réquisitoire définitif reconnaît que le
mobile du crime reproché un mobile n'a
pu être établi n'est recherché
compte tenu des délais trop rapide dans
lesquels l'information a peut être
clôturée voilà qui pose un problème
j'aime bien se qualifie d' un impayable
français moyens on al'impression
vraiment pénible l'énorme machine s'est
mise en route et puis bon canal a été
broyée par sotchi
oui monsieur movida se définit lui-même
dans une de ses lettres comme un
impayable français moyen c'est peut être
la raison pour laquelle ils ne
bénéficient pas d'un large soutien parce
qu'il ne fait après tout que symboliser
la moyenne mais il faut savoir que ce
qui est arrivé à monsieur movil un peu
précisément arriver à n'importe quel
français moyen contrairement aux
principes souvent affirmé selon lequel
un accusé un suspect ne peut être
considéré comme coupable que si
l'accusation fait la preuve irréfutable
de sa culpabilité
on observe bien souvent que c'est à
l'accusé qui est souvent considéré à
brio riz comme coupable de faire la
preuve de son innocence
pas d' indices pas d'empreinte pas de
mobile 18 ans de prison dans les lettres
écrites par mauvillain de sa cellule une
même phrase revient
j'ai espoir en france on ne condamne pas
dans le doute
oui le climat disait en régaler le
climat de l'époque et peut-être aussi le
passé judiciaire de guy mauvillain 25
ans avant ce crime il avait été
poursuivi pour un autre délit mineur ce
qui a pu influencer les jurés à l'issue
du procès d'assises pourvoi en cassation
avait été rejeté une requête en révision
appuyé par le témoignage de la voisine
témoignages que vous venez d'entendre
fut alors déposé peu après la réponse
garde des sceaux fut négative
ce témoignage n'étant pas considérée
comme un fait nous les deux instruisons
tous les environs 80 90 dossier de
révision
ce témoignage a provoqué une enquête une
enquête décidée par le garde des sceaux
une enquête minutieuse et qui au terme
de laquelle est apparu que ce témoignage
n'était pas de nature à établir
l'innocence du condamné dont la
culpabilité était par ailleurs confirmé
selon d'autres éléments sont en fait
j'avais 5 ans certaines personnes qui
est actuellement dénoncé erreur
judiciaire soit en judiciaire la justice
qu'on adresse en 16 es innocent et dans
le même temps ceux qui font ce reproche
à la justice reproche à la justice
également de laisser ce crime impuni
alors l'erreur est humaine
laon judiciaire est possible il faut la
bête avec humilité une décision de
condamnation est intervenue
régulièrement je dis qu'après une
enquête minutieuse fait sur une simple
demande de révision et n'est apparue au
garde des sceaux qui n'avait pas le
droit de demander la révision la cour de
cassation
oui cela dit c'est un dossier qui j'en
suis sûr comme vous faites du trouble et
jean snella est mort son nom était
synonyme de football l'a dit aujourd'hui
de lui raymond kopa ce fut l'entraîneur
de saint-etienne on n'a guère et puis en
58 avec albert batteux il fut
l'entraîneur de l'équipe de france
pendant les championnats du monde en
suède
marius trésor à l'instant confirme son
accord pour être transféré au bayern de
musique de munich la sphère pourrait se
faire très rapidement puisque
l'international pourrait jouer en
allemagne d'ici le 10 décembre et il
aurait un contrat de 2 à 3 ans avec donc
le bayern de munich rugby voici
maintenant la composition de l'équipe de
france qui doit rencontrer le 2 décembre
celle de roumanie je vous laisse la
découvrir donc à l'arrière pas de
surprise aguets et en remplaçant vous le
voyez pas coller des grilles lafargue
pardo et viviès de la danse pour
terminer ce journal
rudolf noureev découvrira ce soir au
public parisien en première mondiale sa
chorégraphie demande fred un ballet
romantique plein de rythmes et de
couleurs qui raconte la vie de lord
byron sur une musique de tchaïkovski
georges bigot était hier au palais des
sports pour assister aux dernières
répétitions
cet homme qui claudique en rejoignant
les danseurs sur le plateau à la fin de
la répétition générale c'est rudolf
noureev les étoiles et le ballet de
l'opéra de paris
laplaud dicks c'est un hommage mérité et
qui n'est pas fréquent noureev s'est
cassé le pied récemment et ne pourra pas
danser le rôle principal de manfred une
belle histoire d'amitié d'amour et d'
aventure qui s'était pourtant taillé sur
mesure c'est jean guizerix qui jouera
tous les soirs ce rôle épuisant 1h10
sans quitter la scène
vous ne regrettez pas trop que cet
accident vous empêche de jouer le
premier rôle
non on va trop déçu
manfred de la danse sera également
évoqué demain antenne de midi avec
georges bigou et daniel bilalian à 12h45
auparavant ce soir juste après les
dossiers de l'écran vers 23h30 donc les
dernières informations vous seront
présentés par paul âme à ce journal ne
serait pas tout à fait complète sans la
météo aujourd'hui de la bretagne à
l'aquitaine il a plu ce matin pluie qui
se sont dissipés au cours de l'après
midi
il a fait beau sur la région
méditerranéenne où le mistral a perdu de
son intensité de main et bien attend bo
dans le sud du pays de faibles pluies
sont possibles près de la manche
sur les autres régions les brouillards
du matin persisteront parfois après
l'après midi sur l'est et le nord-est de
la france
voilà pas encore de résultats du côté de
l'assemblée me dit jacques croiser ce
journal donc tout à fait complet je vous
retrouve avec plaisir demain passer une
excellente soirée bonsoir à tous